ah good to be back you hear that sound
out there somebody revving their car and
two people fighting over a thing of um
it looks like a thing of like one of
those flame logs a fire flame you know
one of those Durrell logs yep it looks
like a - hearty hearty hearty lesbians
out there fighting over a damn dura log
in the street and somebody revving their
car at the same time
I mean Cleveland man uh I'm at the hotel
I'm back from Maui if you hear that
that's just that calm that's inside of
me hey I'm back from that Maui Wow we
here oh hell yeah boy somebody just
somebody heard it somebody won that log
somebody got the fire all themselves
Mahalo Aloha
konichiwa Mahalo
Madagascar I'm back I'm that back a
lantern baby put that candle in me cuz
I'm lit let's get into it there's a song
that I was I just found out from a band
called North Mississippi Allstars and
they they've tuned into this past
weekend and they have a lyric from from
from the podcast that's kind of that
they put into their music and so I want
to play one of their songs right now
it's called drunk outdoors
off their new album up and rolling and
this is the North Mississippi Allstars
[Music]
to us
now
[Music]
yes
ah
[Music]
get that you guys got to check the
tuning out and they really get into it
man and that band right there
that is uh North Mississippi Allstars
and that's a new album they got out
there it's nd out in the out in the in
the universe and the atmosphere and you
can go and check it out and that is uh
that is a song and I hit the man up Cody
Dickinson on his on his instagrams and
and I and I said hey is this true that
you guys heard this on the podcast and
he said yeah man we love it
and so it just really I mean it just
made my balls growl a little you know
that yeah yeah I'm back I'm back from
Maui all had a good time look if you
don't know if you're you know maybe
forty percent sure of something if
you're going to heaven because I think
most people are if they're really honest
with themselves they come in at probably
about forty percent you know so if
you're about forty percent sure that
you're going to heaven then you could go
to Maui and Maui is like I mean it's
there are times I closed my eyes and I
said damn man out if people this place
is gonna give heaven a run for its money
it just I mean it's romantic you could
be by yourself and it feels romantic
dude I felt like everything every time
the breeze came by was trying to just
you know just trying to get me back to
its room it was just that kind of just
that kind of spirit it was just
something you know and the water will
come you'll be laying there taking a nap
and you think you slept you're laying
far enough from the water and about you
know maybe eighteen or thirty you know
thirty or sixty fifty kind of forty
minutes later that water will start
licking at your [ __ ] feet you say day
what's up buck buck buck oh so it's you
know everything there is China you get
home you have some of the beach will be
in your pants some sand like what is it
who is it what is it you're like I hope
this is you know some female saying I
don't want no
you know mail saying trying to get in my
pants but you take your pants off and
say a bunch of sand will jump out of
your pants you said well damn
so just mother nature that's where she
really goes to just get on
I mean Maui just wants to love you and
it really just wants to love you and and
and I stay I noticed after a bit that
the the ocean will start doing your hair
for you yeah it dude I had at one point
I had like a little thing of algae right
above one of my ears you know you got a
little conch over there on the left it's
like you know I look like kind of like
you got like a little seahorse kind of
just hanging off that backsplash I mean
it's I look like you know shunk like you
know like a conch questio you know just
out there with just just the what the
ocean and everything we'll do your hair
for you but I had a wonderful time and I
had so if you haven't been to Maui I
totally recommend it and they say
there's different islands and I want to
go back there and do a show soon and I
want to go to some of the different
islands over there and the people just
people a lot of people I did think this
I felt like there could be even though
it's very wonderful it definitely seems
like a place where some people that
might have done a crime would go to hide
it's got that kind of cry me Heidi sort
of uh you know but but all I was so good
man I just took a week and relaxed and
then I I got back into town and just
decided to take last Sunday off of the
pod and yeah I just wanted to have a
little bit of you know just have a
little respite they call it get a
relaxed in and just get that feeling in
my body you know my sometimes your body
feels like it has like kind of a little
bit of more comfort in it so I was
trying to get you know a touch more that
comfort for myself what else we're now
I'm in Cleveland I'm in Cleveland and
they got a couple of
they got some Hardy they got some Hardy
humans out here Cleveland Pittsburgh
over there back back you had a show last
night in Pittsburgh and who came out uh
some people I know Steve my boy week
Steve came out and you got a known him
for years didn't Steve bro he'll be
shaking your hand you don't even know it
that's how weak he is brusque baffling
this girl dizzy came she's always people
think she's dizzy but she isn't so she's
got that people always like you dizzy
she said no no no you know when she's
always you know kind of dusted out she's
like one of those little dust Muppets
you know she's always up you know she
never really been she don't have a
comfortable relationship with gravity
that's kind of how I feel it because
most of us you know we're gravity
addicts if you fight you know most of us
you think you know you say hey what are
you doing you're doing I mean we don't
talk about it but everybody's doing
gravity everybody but this dude is he
wish he gets out there and she she ain't
really doing it as much as everybody
else so she's you know kind of living
she's kind of like that uh she's kind of
like a Native American when it comes to
really force fields and stuff you know
she's kind of doing her own thing she's
kind of working freelance when it comes
to natural pull the natural pull of the
world what else oh I feel like so I want
to tell you more about Maui I'll
probably wait to get back into the
studio I guess what I went there oh let
me tell you this you go to Mama's fish
house and they got it's in Maui and it's
nice you get there you're like aw it's
too nice you know it's real it's kind of
it looks fancy made oof right when I got
there I thought to myself I want to
steal something I'm gonna go that's how
nice it was that's my initial reaction
but instead who sit down relax
even if you're by yourself get you a
little non-alcoholic beer you feel me
get a um one of the crab cakes I got the
crab cake that's it get one crab cake
unbutton your pants welcome to Palestine
Sun [ __ ] is fundamentally good it was it
was definitely one of the best meals I
ever had and I was by myself too and um
yeah when I'm by myself at a restaurant
I start to you almost start to freak out
a little because you start wondering if
people think you're like in witness
protection or if you're you know people
kind of look at you like you maybe your
spouse just passed away or something
they give you that you know they maybe
give you a little extra bread or
something half an extra little you know
baked uh you know little little
croissant piece or something because
they think maybe your wife's gone she
you know they think so or you know you
they think maybe you don't know what
you're doing with your life if it is
interesting if you go to a restaurant by
yourself people kind of look at you like
ah maybe he you know you know maybe he's
still trying to do skateboarding or
something but but he's too old for it oh
one of the things that got me at the
restaurant was the guy trying to upsell
me on our soup look don't I don't I
don't need it don't the guy you know
he's like oh they got omegas in the soup
dude I don't give a damn if Voltron
lives in that [ __ ] dude I don't care if
I want the soup I'm getting the soup you
know he said it's got a rare carrot base
what the hell is that buddy
that's nothing dude I don't care I don't
care if you open my mouth and just drag
me through mr. McGregor's garden if I
want vegetables I want vegetables just
don't upsell me on it
you know he's telling me he tell me oh
we sprinkled the top of it with secrets
[ __ ] don't care if I want the soup I'll
get the soup
you know I just I don't like being up
Seoul with trickery words you know oh
this you know the the the haricot vert
was blessed by um a cleft palate wizard
i don't give a dang but do not upsell me
with the BS just give me the facts what
is it is it soup and if I wanted I'll
get it yeah and I was hitting went to
Pittsburgh last night went to Bethlehem
out there this dude came out one of my
boys from back in a day came out he's
three months clean off duster y'all know
duster you know the keyboard you know
kind of helps you keep your keyboard
nice so he's got three months clean off
that dust or so that was you know it was
kind of nice to it you know just embrace
him and we would always do that sound
that in his ear all the time you know
just just a freaking you know get him
squirrel on a little just to let the let
his branches shake a little but we had a
good time in Bethlehem I hadn't been on
a stage in a couple of weeks and it's
kind of like it kind of gets a little
nerd and I guess is it nerve-wracking
yeah it gets because you built up this
immunity kind of you know the more that
I'll be on stage the more immunity I
will feel a little bitter at least just
the more confidence builds up until
you're just you know it's like you've
been training almost and then you take a
couple weeks off the train and train and
uh yeah it was uh and it's nice ma'am
and it was really really relaxing and
Bethlehem was great the show in
Bethlehem was really you know it just uh
I guess I'm just amazed how many people
come out you know and especially since I
you know change the dates and then
change them back I just want to thank
you guys for coming out of support and
supporting me in just so many nice
people I mean everybody was just really
enjoying themselves I met a lot of
people before the show
we did meet and greet' after the show
and then and everybody that wanted to
come so we had a good group and i think
a lot of people left but a lot of people
stayed and um yeah it was just you know
it's nice it was nice because sometimes
it's like you know with this job you
feel like okay well and I guess since
its kind of new for me it's like okay
well you know if I go to the club or
people gonna be you know if I take a
break or take you know you know like
take a little break or take some time
off or people still gonna be there and
you know it was nice to see that people
were in Pittsburgh they had some dude
was blasted in Pittsburgh I didn't think
he was on drinking I think this guy was
on something thicker like maybe you know
maybe a friend of his had been doing a
lot of smack or something or you know
doing I don't even know something and
then he was drinking that guy's blood
you know like maybe his buddy was damn
drinking damn quick Creed or something
or drywall and he uh and then he was
drinking that guy's blood he was doing a
mess there this guy was bent out so I
hope he's doing a little bit better it
was a rock club the place we were at the
place is called the Roxy and theater and
it was cool man they said they never had
this was the first comedy show that
they'd ever had there so that was a new
experience for them and um and it's in
this place called McKees Rocks and they
said it's an area for um human
trafficking but I didn't I didn't see
anything like that I didn't I mean the
only thing on the menu was even I think
beer and wine so I didn't have any you
know there was nothing to me that really
I didn't see I was just doing comedy but
everybody in the crowd looked of age and
you know not being kind of purchased or
anything so so that was at and then came
to Cleveland early went to the Steelers
game man that was
it blew me away how amazing the
experience was I mean it's just people I
mean they got some real they got men and
women with the same damn haircut
you know you know what I'm sayin they
got men and women with the same haircut
and thankthank every other person ate
they kind of had that wild old school
kind of Pittsburgh yen's er that hanging
every don't even hang and you'll see but
people like to eat before the tailgate
you'll see yet I went behind a trail
that one dude was uh injecting a slice
of supreme pizza into his arm so damn
bruh my bad man he was five guys getting
bent out and it's uh yeah everybody was
friendly I mean that the atmosphere was
amazing you go into the game everybody
has this towel and um it's kind of like
one of those little towels if a baby
spits up that you're gonna have like a
towel for it you know and at first I
didn't know I thought I'm like dang
everybody here has a baby I guess and
they you know or what's going on but it
turns out that um it's called the
Terrible Towel and it's just I guess if
something real terrible happens and you
have like uh you have a towel which
actually really is helpful
you know because you got to take care of
yourself and a lot of things could
happen over there you know in Pittsburgh
everybody knows I got pinkeye over there
you know back in the day and I got a I
got a pretty strong case of pinkeye was
in the Monongahela actually and I got a
little bit of you know some got got a
little bit of don tying him up pon you
know somebody you know they had you know
I don't know what was in a river feet
you know I guess VC or whatever but
anyway it was um but then also in the
same city in my next visit
I got a got a blow job behind a Giant
Eagle grocer so you know six and
one-half dozen the other
you know just when you think life in the
turnaround you know it does a damn
u-turn so that's how life is bro you
know that's how life is I guess I don't
know I don't have any idea what I'm
talking about um and then we came yeah
now we're here in Cleveland so we can
hear here to Cleveland ari manases with
me oh I saw Brendan I stopped over I saw
Brendan Schaub the other night he was at
the Pittsburgh improv snuck over there
and welcomed him onto stage I was pretty
fun good to see him always and this week
I'm coming up to some different places
I'll tell you a few show dates at the
moment to you know be in Cleveland this
Tuesday there's still a few tickets left
and then the rest of this week I'll be
in Indianapolis Detroit Grand Rapids
Milwaukee and Madison yep that's it
and maybe one other place actually let
me look right now also December 10th
I'll be at The Wiltern in Los Angeles
you can go see that that's downtown in
Los Angeles oh one thing that was cool
in Bethlehem all different the backstage
that had posters of all the groups that
have played on the stage and they had I
mean Guns and Roses man they had a you
know who else you know Twisted Sister
man acid bath you know Reba McEntire's
you know Georgia Florida line they had
everybody
there wasn't one Florida Georgia line
there wasn't one
everybody had come through there they uh
Neil Haggard was I got Merle Haggard and
he's dead man so you got to think just
the just it was just amazing to be there
I'm like jeepers you know to get to have
that experience and so just thank you
for everybody that came out I know kind
of all over the place but I'm just
settling back in
you know I'm just settling back in and
it was nice to get a little bit of a
break because just to kind of get a
little look at what was going on you
know just to kind of get a little look
at what has been going on in my own
career and and in my own personal life
and everything you know and I was
thinking about like you'd ever since I
was young I like to have like secrets
kinda I like to keep things some things
to myself you know I like to just keep
it always had like a maybe not even a
secret more like a little treasure or
something you know when I was a kid I
used to collect Dom you know different
snacks and stuff like that like my mom
wouldn't let us have a lot of sugars and
different stuff and so they so I would
collect a lot of different sugar treats
you know different snacks different you
know um snicker KitKat baby snicker
everything different thing Butterfinger
different thing you know just a little
sack of sugar somebody spilled some
sugar somewhere I'll get that you know a
chocolate a white chocolate something
like that a cookie a rare macaroon or
something you know a you know an Italian
cookie and I would put them a raisins
even sometimes I would soak raisins in
chocolate milk and just so that they
would have that kind of flavor in them
and that sweet sweetness and I used to
bury him outside right I'll put all put
them all in like a little sack and
because my mom would let me keep him in
the house as she if if my mother found
him there was gone the snacks were gone
and so I used to keep him outside off to
the side of the house and I had me a
little you know digging area and I would
just dig real lightly get that sack out
and sugar up but it sometimes I would go
out there at nighttime and you know what
nighttime is it's when it's you know
it's when you can't see that much but
you kind of know everything is around
kind of but aren't as sure as you were a
few hours earlier
and the and so I have to wait till a car
went by on our street because I had to
wait till that car went by and the
headlights I could see the snacks and I
could see the area to dig and I would
dig real quick and you know have me a
sugar snack or have me a night Tom's you
know a soup you know uh you know a sweet
treat and I never told him I never told
anybody till this till right now
actually except for this one boy named
Wayne and he was big man he's a big boy
and some people called him fat Wayne and
and I probably did once or twice but I
don't think I did it
III would never say it to him I would
just sometimes say it out do you know
and then I would say it you know but um
but anyway he would come over he saw me
out there getting him one night and so
he would come over sometime he would
steal his dad's car he would get it over
and put the headlights on and turn them
right on the grass on the area and that
way the lights were right there yet full
lighting because otherwise you had to
wait till a car went past and some cars
don't have that brighter lights on them
see some time would wait till you were
lucky if you had an SUV or something or
somebody driving by with like a real
real bright Lantern or something and you
could see this you know see the off
snacks real well and quickly but
sometimes Wayne would pull his dad's car
over and when I say pull he would put it
in a neutral and he pushed that [ __ ]
over and that was when I was growing up
that was like kind of an early way of
kind of driving a little bit it's just
push getting that thing in a neutral and
just pushing that [ __ ] around the
neighborhood you know he'd tell a girl
you say hey look I'm gonna be I'm gonna
come I'm akimichi around 8:00 around
8:15 8:00 28:19 and then you get in the
car once your folks went to sleep or
went in their room you get in there and
put that car into neutral and then push
it you know push that bastard down to uh
to your girl's house or you know if you
were secretly in love with a young man
or something could push it to his house
but most often see some
pushing it over to a female's house and
you pull up in the yard and then you try
to get in real quiet cuz you didn't want
her knowing you didn't drive there
you wanted a trick or so you would park
and then go get her say hey what's going
on yeah just drove down meanwhile you
you know you're just covering and sweat
you know I mean you just pushed her you
know in 1991 Oldsmobile or a Ford Taurus
you just push that thing about eight
blocks and you usually had a little bit
of an erection to if you're gonna see a
you know a girl you were interested in
or even a young man if he were
interested in something like that but
you didn't see a lot of that but and
that should be a contest or an Olympic
sport I think I've said that before that
you know doing sports with an erection
because your brain is going to have less
blood to function in your body and
muscles are gonna have less blood if
some of your you know some of your
wiener is kind of bogarting a little bit
of that be positive you feel me or own
egative or whatever you got whatever
electrons you got in your flow you feel
me
praise God man what else is going on um
oh I don't know I feel like a ton and
then I feel like nothing that's kind of
what I feel like if you like sex then
you'll love blue chew dot-com blue chew
offers men a performance enhancement for
the bedroom a lot of time you see a guy
to get a bed that's one of those
vibrating beds you know you put a
quarter into my chain at the end and the
bed starts vibrating you know get the
wife active but at blue chew calm you
can get the first chewable wiener
inhibitor it has the same active
ingredients as viagra and Silas the
chewables from blue chew can be taken on
a full or empty stomach man can you
imagine you can run your dick on an
empty stomach and that is the power of
blue chew calm it ships directly to your
door and
discreet packaging no more that bright
yellow or pink packaging saying hey they
got Wiener helpers in here
the chewables from blue chew comm are
prescribed online by a doctor and made
in the USA and here's a great deal for
you
tpw listeners visit blue chew comm and
get your first order free when you use
promo code Theo just pay $5 shipping
that's BL you e CH e w dot-com and use
promo code Theo get that Weiner hitter
hiring can be a slow process you know so
now I was remember back in the old days
you would write up put a little note on
on a log or something or ink up um
vestibule or something you know write a
note in blood or something on the wall
hey I need help I need you know I need
someone to do dishwashing or someone to
do filing or someone to you know help
process uh this court case but that's
different now you know that's different
people are finding jobs and filling jobs
through zip recruiter zip recruiter
doesn't depend on candidates finding you
it finds them for you so it does it
recruiters that hunter what if you do a
hound dog you say oh go get me something
give me a cut of ham zip recruiter is
that hound zip recruiters technology
identifies people with the right
experience and invites them to apply to
your job so you get qualified candidates
fast
that's how Dylan Mischka wits hired his
new director of coffee for his organic
coffee company because he was having
trouble finding qualified qualified
applicants with results like that it's
no wonder four out of five employers who
post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day that's
amazing
so you can see why's it recruiter is
effective for businesses of all sizes
try zip recruiter for free at our web
address zip recruiter dot-com slash tpw
zip recruiter dot-com slash tpw zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire and
now back to your
episode the date for New Jersey and the
date for Maryland oxen Hill the MGM
Grand those are both being rescheduled
and you should get a date here through
the email shortly and just thank you
everybody for just support me while I
could just you know kind of cancel the
dates and then put them back on you know
it's just just been a lot going on in my
brain and you know sometimes I don't
know what I'm doing you know when it
comes to like a big picture sense and
I'm just trying my best and you know
sometimes it's okay and sometimes it's
well it's always okay but just thanks
for supporting me while I figure it off
you know well I just learn as I go and
never reminds me just to do that with
other people as well so I'm glad that uh
that I have that reminder let's take a
couple of calls that came in because you
know we got this episode right here on
the road we got a set up pretty uh Ari
Mantis came in and really helped me set
up really helped me set up got Jocko
willing coming in to do an episode so
I'm I'm grateful that that man is gonna
come in and oh I got to tell you this so
I was just thinking that Jacko's kind of
you know he's like an older brother
figure but for me I can be real father
figures from me
you know I noticed that I'm I have such
a desperation for that energy in that
connection in my life that you know I
will latch on to people or put them in a
place where without even realizing it
that I have of that I give that up I
take you know kind of father figure like
type of stuff off of them and Jocko is
like that jakka willing and and he uh oh
this what I was thinking
so I saw my dad in a dream when I was in
Hawaii or in Maui sorry when I was in
Maui and it was it was really crazy
because I hadn't seen him in 20 years
even in a vision you know when I had to
a dolt and and I saw him you know when I
saw mean it was crazy we read up it was
kind of confusing it was a dream you
know and Robert De Niro was there and
Matthew McConaughey was there and we
were in Maui and I my dad was in one
room eating at a table and Matthew
McConaughey and Robert De Niro were in
another room and my dad wanted to come
and meet Matthew McConaughey but he
didn't want to meet Robert De Niro and
so I was trying to like mediate between
the two of them
and finally my dad and Matthew
McConaughey got to meet each other which
doesn't mean anything but it was just
interesting to see my father I hadn't
seen him you know I'd seen him in
pictures and I'd seen him and just you
know imagine natan what our imagination
what his what he looked like or
something but I hadn't seen him really
and he made me think that my dad lives
in Hawaii or something you know like I
was like oh is this where he's been and
it made me think well of course this is
where he's been this is where I would be
it is stunning
paia that's where I went to Pai a and I
stayed out at this place called lumeria
and they don't have I don't even stir
were some moments I don't know if they
even had it's very peaceful and
beautiful little staff that works there
and there were some of them so I didn't
know if people were they are working or
staying or anything or there was a day
where I didn't see anyone anybody
and it's you know it's comfortable I
mean they don't have what don't I have
they don't have it's they don't have
they don't have air conditioning in the
rooms but I knew that going into it and
I wanted it kind of more of a I guess
bohemian experience but they have fans
and you can get like a portable and
brought in which I finally did on the
fourth day but uh but yeah I got to see
my dad man I got to see him it was it
was I just didn't know I didn't know
that he's been in Hawaii ever been him
you know that he's been there and he was
healthy he was healthier looking than
I've ever seen him in my whole life when
I actually saw him
that's what's wild he was kind of
thicker he'd been eaten and his hair his
hair was darker and he was laughing man
he was laughing and he uh and he was a
little he was she was kind of being cool
trying to add a little bit play it cool
or be cool I guess I don't know I mean
he you know I mean he lives in that
world and the subconscious or in dream
war so I you know I have no idea what
his life is like there he may drive a
Corvette I don't know I didn't see you
know the parking lot or anything like
that I just saw you know just him um and
man right when I got up I've just been
on this kick where I've just been trying
to stay more motivated and like when I
get when it's time to get up it's time
to get up and I need to do things and
you know I just want my life to be I
want to have more experiences in my life
you know recently I've just been
realizing like I do a lot of stuff but
it's a lot of the same things and I'm
not really having a lot of like new
experiences and so I want to have a
little bit more of that but uh but man I
wish I'd I just laid back down and tried
to go right back and see him you know
wherever he was and but it's just so
funny I mean I've slept and you know in
the past 20 years I'd probably fallen
asleep and you know 40 to stay
and you know fifteen or twenty or thirty
[ __ ] you know I don't know countries and
not once did I see my father and then I
am I'm in Maui and there he is
maybe he's over there maybe you know
with Dog the Bounty Hunter dude but it
was quite an experience and Aloha and
Mahalo those are things I learned and
one time there was somebody vomiting
behind a truck and I thought they were
doing ten Mahalo but it was a woman you
know had a little bit too much fermented
fruit you feel me she had a little too
much nap in her pineapple dog and she
was vomiting over there behind a um a
little Isuzu truck rare truck you don't
see those as much as you used to anymore
and I'll tell you this over there on
interstate 12 or i-10 I saw a Doberman
full-grown Doberman commit suicide jump
right out of the back of a Chevrolet
truck I believe it was or something or
maybe I had to just jump right on onto
the interstate at 60 70 miles an hour so
you know you just don't know what people
anybody's going through sometimes it's
that is that kind of world so we just
got to take care of each other the
hotline I got a couple calls that came
in as always the number nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three and
let's get some of these hitters right
here yeah yeah man I'm so excited for
this week yes so just so many fun places
to do shows let's check out let's take a
call what's up Colin from Harrisburg
thank you for calling beautiful state I
mean driving we drove five hours of the
day we did the Pittsburgh show that day
and man it's just beautiful you know we
saw a couple Amish
and we try to go you know we didn't want
to get too close to him because it was
like around lunchtime or whatever but we
saw a couple and we tried to you know we
like pretended we weren't taking likes
getting them in the back of our pitchers
and stuff but yeah beautiful state the
trees are just starting to change color
and I mean it just this is what Mother
Nature really shows that work you know
this where mother nature really uh
bounces that ass a little if you will
sorry to get kind of urban right there
let's hear more thank you for calling
home take my wife with me and she's
never seen you before and she ended up
loving it so I think we got a new family
you think honey oh yeah wear that look
where I grew up all over down Magee
street and Cummington Louisiana bra
if a girl spit sprite onto you dude
y'all probably gonna end up touching
each other dude you know what I'm sayin
that's sexual right there if somebody
spit sprite on you bro so you feel that
splash but also you can still get it out
of your clothing it's not one of those
you know caramel color beverages oh you
know a Coke or or a Pepsi or a tab you
need that's foreplay that's five play
baby
seeing that sprite just splash off your
hard skin dawg
yeah
so y'all better make a baby bro you feel
me do bring that baby back next year
let's hear a little more right now it
was a great show I was you know really
good to see you man I hope to see you
again soon all right man take care okay
gang bro
dang bro well good I'm glad you and your
lady came out we had a guy that came out
and brought his brother out over there
yesterday and uh in Pittsburgh that was
pretty nice to see him and his brother
came out these two it looked kind of
Irish but something also I don't know if
they were or not but uh they had a
father son that came out of it in
Bethlehem they had a mother daughter
came one of them gave me this really
nice little booklet of like positive
affirmations and stuff a lot of good
people so I'm glad I'm glad you and your
girl enjoyed it you know and I hope you
gave her that hit or dare do you feel me
son because we got to eat it we got to
procreate we got to get out there and
make them pop baby and do that
and do sex you know if you love each
other and if you were if you guys are
already living the same house you might
as well I'm saying cross paths with the
across brother let's take another call
that came in here as always the hotline
is nine eight five six six four nine
five zero three what's up
fyodor what's up brother thank you for
hitting it up gang
big Jack it's your time of year to with
them Jack O'Lanterns they you might as
well knock one of your teeth out you
know and really just and live the life
and you know paint you know paint your
head orange a knock on your own damn
teeth out and eat a light you know eat a
little 30-watt or something and live
hard this month Oh word I'm driving
right now in a car I've been in a car
for about three hours now three and a
half hours now and oh damn you might be
in a high-speed chase bro you better
look out you better look behind you and
see if there's activity you know see if
there's a little bit of you know a
couple of dodge dip
matze and some gunplay let's hear more
brother mas I'm driving because I'm
going to ask my girlfriend's father if I
can marry her and I'm not a hundred
percent sure if he's gonna say yes oh
yeah Wow hmm well I'll shut up let's
hear more from human so my question to
you is you know how do i how do I
confront them about the head wise
navigate this conversation if he does
tell me no what do I do you know so yeah
I just want to put that out there for
you because you are a wise young man
so yeah just let me know give me a call
back and well I'll tell you I'll uh I'll
let you know right now what I what I
think about it is if you're asking to
somebody's dad to marry you first of all
it's it's nice of you to do because
that's the old-school tradition you know
there was a time back in the day where
people you know if you didn't really
like you know if if you you know you're
a girl if you grow if you you know wife
got out of line they went missing this
is 300 years ago or so you know 70 years
ago probably but but there was a time
where you know where you know men
probably weren't treating women as good
and so I think you getting over there
and asking him I think it's a pro move
if he says no bro
I think you got to probably move on
because you don't want to be Aida's I
wouldn't want to be at odds then your
girl's gonna become this middleman
between you and the dad or if he says no
I would take some boxing gloves over
there cuz I bet any man that gets to
punch his son-in-law a couple times I
bet at some point they
you know they beat they beat them into
somebody that they could love so you got
some choices boy and I'm glad you have
at least somebody at least you have
somebody to drive across town and check
you know I could drive across town right
now down there to New Orleans I you know
a girl I used to date and and her dad
would be like what the [ __ ] we haven't
seen you in 15 years
so that would be you know and they they
over there they used to make due to snow
cone makers so you know at least you
that would be a funny show if a guy just
pulled up over it
like a hey uh if I got his pulled up
over walked up to an older guy on the
street was like sir I just want to ask
you for your daughter's hand in marriage
I think it wouldn't be a bad move it
would be easier than approaching a
female a lot of times because a lot of
times fortunate female can make a man
nervous but if you got to approach that
male and say hey bucko you know hey Jim
you could even just guess his name you
know four out of probably 22 times it's
gonna be Jim hey Jim I uh you know you
don't know me but I've been seeing your
daughter and you know I love her you
know she's the apples of my eyes and she
you know she chips out on my rent and I
love her we bought a Super NES together
and uh and things are looking up so I
think that there's a that would be a
great little kind of fun little show
just to see because then if the dad just
even if he kind of agrees and likes you
then you could probably get to meet the
daughter and at least have a chance
maybe with her so that way you're kind
of working backwards but if you're
choosing to work forwards the old
fashioned way I say if y'all are gonna
live in the same city and he says no
then I think you got oh you might want
to look into somebody else but if he
says yes man
then get into it man y'all do a barbecue
get matching aprons you know saying go
full-throttle do matching shirts and
then buy a little dog that looks like
just you and this in the end and the
father-in-law you know live your best
life brother you can do it what else man
let me let me get this other call that
came in right here the hotline is always
is nine eight five six six four nine
five zero three here we go hey you know
this is Tait from Atlanta what up Tate
thanks for calling in brother
I appreciate it first off sorry I found
a extra life today I'm a little stuffy
I'm getting over a cold so maybe don't
stand to fuss too close to the phone's I
don't want to get you sick bruh but
anyways I wouldn't solve that new jerker
movie last night oh yeah then we're
gonna see it some more actually and I
love face pain anyway let's hear more it
was pretty good but uh I know all the
news outlets and all were reporting that
people might want to be aware that these
in cells might be there those movie
premieres inciting violence and all that
I was like what's an in cell so I looked
it up and it's involuntary celibates
it's just like internet group of dudes
who can't get any action and take it out
on women because they think that it's
their problem somehow and and I was
wondering where your thoughts on that
that's just kind of weird to me I think
it's a weird culture we live in and the
internet forums and all that can breathe
them there's some really weird monster
people you know so uh yeah anyway
appreciate it of what you're doing
oh thanks man thank you for uh sorry
pain gang stay safe out there men gang
brah stay safe too and it is Halloween
month so it's that time of year where
somebody will you know dress up like a
giraffe and hit you with a hatch at her
son you know for no reason and just say
they were looking for candy or whatever
no get off scot-free because these
attorneys in all this [ __ ] but yet
they're in Cellular's I don't do it you
know I think there's a lot of soft batch
people out there now there's a lot of
guys that struggle you know if you
struggle to meet women and struggle to
you know converse with women and
struggle to form relationships that's
one that's one thing but if you find
that you have a real anger towards women
you know that's something else you got
to deal with you can't be dressing you
know you can't be dressing up like you
know like Christopher Robin's or
whatever and you know throwing you know
throwing like wooden swords and [ __ ] at
like local [ __ ] in your area that's
you know that's not that kind of that's
that's no way to you know it's almost
we're heading into the holidays I mean
Jesus so I don't and also the news I
don't believe anything in News says I
really don't know
I don't believe ever since remember when
they said that about the election before
they had the presidential election
they're like Oh Hillary's gonna win this
much and all the all the polls they had
done and and then they were just wrong
they were just wrong about everything
and at that point I realized oh the news
it used to be like facts and now it's
just people guessing [ __ ] with cameras
so I think the movies going to be fine I
think the news is just trying to scare
people you know I think there's some
guys out there but they're tightening up
that's what I think and things are
looking up have a little bit of red meat
maybe or have some strong broccoli you
know do something eat a half at that you
know drink half a thing of [ __ ]
Elmer's you know do something tighten up
and feel strong I think there's a lot of
young men that are feeling stronger than
ever you know it's like the news is
always say you know does racism and this
Annette wrote when I was in Pittsburgh
for the game today I saw so much like
non racism probably more than I've ever
seen
and I was like oh yeah once again
everything's going fine
now I don't think I don't think it's a
bad idea to stay strapped if you need to
these days wherever you're going you
know if they have a legal law where you
can carry a weapon I don't think you
need to be alarming people like my
cousin Jamie and he would you know he
popped out from behind the computer you
know the computer desk with two guns on
him and he was in his underpants and so
he Jesus Christ dude and he has a
deviated septum and I had to listen to
him snore for probably I can't even tell
you it sounded like a couple of whales
trying to meet each other and you know
what I'm like a very distant Beach but I
don't know I'm talking about man but
I'll say this bro you got to take care
of yourself dude
tighten up and keep tightening up that's
what you can do that's what you can do
and look have a plan if you do have
don't don't be the jackoff that's
sitting in the movie with no plan you
know going there have a little bit of a
plan no matter what have an escape plan
you know if you're going in with your
girl you know where heart you know do
something have a little shield or
something do something just have a
little plan but I think overall that
things are everything's gonna be okay I
don't think things are getting that
squirrelly but then also if they have
people that are in cells dude I don't
know I guess we'll be I guess well I
guess we'll beat them somehow you know
we will defeat them when it all goes
down that's what I'm hoping and I'm
gonna go see the movie tomorrow and I'm
gonna get some damn Milk Duds or
whatever dude or some jujubes and chill
and I think a lot of these in cellular
fellow's are a lot of them probably are
men that feel you know they don't they
feel so probably anger towards women
you know there's bent there was a
movement and I don't know if it's still
as heavy as it was but where a lot of
women were just being mean towards men
you know just being mean you know and
they were kind of using
the guise of feminism but really just
being this mean and a lot of times it's
like lonely women and writing these
articles about how bad men are and
they're just lonely why don't just write
a article it says hey I'm you know what
and sometimes I'm lonely did everybody
could really relate to that article but
just being a real bi TCH
with a pen because you are lonesome
sometimes that's not super helpful miss
you know and so I think a lot of these
men that are attacking women sometimes
they feel they feel attacked probably
and I'm not saying it's right you know
you're not supposed to hit a woman but
also a lot of women these days they're
not these aren't the same women from
fifty years ago when a woman you know
was dude they didn't have gymnasiums and
they didn't have you know women weren't
doing a lot of you know strength
training and you know throwing all axes
and all of this or throwing you know big
leg you know pushing sled lit and now
you have it's dude they got do to a
buddy of mine his wife hit him with a
car so he can't hit her when he can't
punch her in the shoulder one time so
what is the rule then what is going on
there
you know I mean his wife hit him with a
damn LeSabre not the sort of Buick so
what you can't he can't tight you know
he can't rattle one off one time or put
her in a you know a rear naked choke for
30 seconds there's got to be some rules
sometimes but I don't just think for
sheer anger you can just be attacking
women out in the street that's not going
to help anything so but this makes me
think about pornography man I've been
struggling with the dark arts brother
I'll be honest with you you know about
three months ago I have this blocker on
my phone that keeps pornography off and
it it's somehow the it updater didn't
update and next thing you know
man the whole just I mean Satan's just
just like Satan's bellybutton opened up
it was like he was a pinata and his
belly button just opened up and just
started spilling dirty candies all over
me so I've been struggling with a little
bit of that and I turned on some
blockers they have on the iPhone they're
like innate blockers built into the
system you know natural blockers that
Apple has but I want to get that full
throttle and get back to the thing that
I had going on before so but just a
timing I'm not an insult I don't think
but you know I'm kind of in and out sell
like I'm in and then I'm out I'm out and
then I mean sometimes I feel you know
like I'm okay sometimes I feel like I'm
not I think I'm just cellular that's
what I am I'm not in cellular about
cellular really I'm just cellular we all
are you know that's the building blocks
of us that's what they said or that's
Adams maybe what what else do we have I
mean we got more you know everything is
going pretty smooth people are always
like when are you gonna shoot a special
I'm gonna shoot one I don't know when
you don't want to I want to take this
the show to the people first and take it
to whoever will come and see it first
and I still got to get over there and
Europe all those shows are in January so
that's gonna be really amazing right
after Christmas get over there while
it's still cold and just see what it's
like to see like cold Europeans you know
because a lot of times when you think
about Europeans you think about them
being warm or being like in a warm area
you know we're wearing like kind of a
summer kind of outfit but this will be a
different experience so really keen on
having that and yeah just happy to be
ink happy to be in Cleveland you know
I'm happy to be in Cleveland and I'm
happy to be on the road and and just and
getting these shows out there to
everybody getting to go to Indianapolis
and Grand Rapids places where I see like
you know I see Chris D'Elia he travels
to these places and I'm like man I want
to be there and now I get to be there
and uh gang gang man is so you know what
I'm saying let's get it let's really
really get it all right I'll see you
guys this week what else they got new
merch online um we got the show at The
Wiltern coming up December 10th in Los
Angeles that'll be on sale coming soon
some really neat guests I think they're
gonna be coming up on the podcast and
I'm spacing them out now to give myself
a little bit more downtime and um and
I'm learning as I go man yeah we got
this call that came in actually uh about
those shows onward hey what's up video
this is Isis from on and on and on Isis
uh-huh
just one letter from being a murderous
regime my brother a regime Oh word that
Canadian hater all from Canada gang
brother onward brought gig cannot say
that next weekend
my brother and I am taking my brother
out for a early birthday early 30th
birthday and we can to to the dirty D to
see you down in Detroit at the Fillmore
the both big plans so we're stoked man
were gonna going to spend spend some
time in the pool
maybe maybe had a few adult beverages
gang bro I like it and I got a I think
my boy damn longneck DLN will be out
there in Detroit - so if we can get his
long ass out and about you know and he's
beautiful my he could travel with him he
could put his ass in a violin case and
that's how he is boy you know he's got
that Clara neck bro you could put him
right in that beautiful musical case and
so I'm happy that my man will be out
there let's go out on the same song that
you brought us a man with just a crazy
week to know that you know we're just on
here and then North Mississippi Allstars
my best friend's been listening to this
band for probably 12 years or something
and and just to find out that they you
know that they through
of our lyric center of one of our lyrics
any of their songs or just that they
were even thinking about us you know
that's pretty cool man so thank you guys
for your patience and and be good to
yourself you know I know you deserve it
and let's go get it man let's go get it
you know let's stay motivated and let's
keep it moving you know unless you get
that header come on with North
Mississippi Allstars and up and rolling
off their new album this drunk outdoors
[Music]
you talk outdoors
stop you talk outdoors if you got money
get a little bigger ain't got money get
that hitter
get back here
[Music]
[Applause]
18:11 Pico Boulevard on the way to the
beach
[Music]
get that
let's go get drunk outdoors
[Music]
go get drunk outdoor
came out
[Music]
see this wild rock is that it
I want to thank my man already man is
for helping me out here on the road and
uh him being a part of making this
happen this episode said tonight we you
know had to set the lamps up in the room
and you know never ceases to amaze me
how you know how he's always part of the
solution no matter what the problem is
constantly reminded you guys be good to
yourselves man you deserve it and uh
Allah and we'll see each other next week
all right gang